I don't know where Donald Trump's impeachment
will ultimately end other than to say, as
I've said before, it's really unlikely that
impeachment is going to actually force Donald
Trump out of the White House through an impeachment
conviction.
I don't see that as even remotely likely,
but the possibility of an impeachment inquiry
and proceedings in the house, uh, is increasing
every day and it actually could be damaging
enough to Donald Trump to help remove him
in 2020 every single day.
Since the testimony of former special prosecutor
Robert Mueller last week, we have seen more
and more Democrats say, I support an impeachment
inquiry and I support it now by the latest
count 105 Democrats in the House of Representatives
support starting an impeachment inquiry of
Donald Trump.
Now as a reminder, an impeachment inquiry
is only step one.
In order to remove a president via impeachment,
you need an impeachment inquiry, which leads
to formalizing the impeachment proceedings.
Then you have an investigation and a trial
after which the Senate has to vote to convict
with a two thirds majority.
So we're very, very far from that.
It is extraordinarily unlikely we are going
to get to that, but we may well get, and we
could even argue that Jerry Nadler has already
defacto started an impeachment inquiry.
Let's look at some examples of Democrats who
are now saying they're in favor of this.
One example is congressman Denny heck who
said on Twitter quote, after considerable
reflection and prayerful consideration, don't
know why you need to pray to God to figure
this one out.
It's pretty clear.
I have decided to support a formal impeachment
inquiry.
Another example of congresswoman came Schrier
who said the people of the eighth district
of Washington elected me to protect their
health care and our environment.
Those will always remain my focus while I
have the privilege of serving them in Congress.
They also helped me, uh, elected me to uphold
the constitution.
So I am formally calling for unimpeachable
inquiry.
This is now a defacto miniature get out the
vote campaign within Democrats in the House
of Representatives because the number right
now is 105 Democrats want an impeachment inquiry.
Informally, they haven't signed on to anything,
but they have said, this is what we want.
There are 435 seats in the House of Representatives.
Half is two 17 plus one.
Uh, there are 235 Democrats.
Republicans are not needed in order to start
an impeachment inquiry that is important to
remember.
Here is judiciary committee chairman Jerry
Nadler admitting that there are currently
impeachment resolutions before the committee
that are being considered.
Meaning this is very close to getting going.
So, so how much of this debate over whether
or not the house isn't pursuing impeachment
is a semantic debate?
You have an impeachment inquiry going, don't
you?
We are examining, I'll just repeat what we
have said.
In our court filings.
We are, we have impeachment resolutions
before the committee.
We are conducting investigations to determine
whether we should report those, uh, impeachment
or resolutions to the house or whether we
should draft our own and report them to the
house or we are considering those resolutions
and we will make a determination after we
get more, uh, evidence, uh, as to the president's,
uh, crimes that we had from the Mallory report,
but also has to other things, uh, as to his
violations of the monuments closed.
Importantly, even Nancy Pelosi has sort of
changed her tune about impeachment, if not
her substantive position.
She now says that the house would decide whether
to begin impeachment proceedings quote, when
we have a best, strongest possible case suggesting
that maybe she's understanding that there
could be a strategic timing element to this
entire thing.
Yet she is still saying that the time for
the impeachment inquiry is not right now,
which 105 other Democrats are saying is the
case, but she has started to shift her language
around as well.
So understand that any day, any day with relatively
little notice, we might learn that the house
has launched an impeachment inquiry.
And if you thought that Donald Trump's behavior
has been a Radek the last two and a half years,
you ain't seen nothing yet.
Just wait until Donald Trump's behavior explodes.
If indeed this gets going.
Now it's important to understand.
I've said it before and I'll say it again.
Impeachment is not without risk.
There's the facts of the situation and there
are the political considerations, as I've
said before, the fact more than support and
impeachment inquiry in particular, Donald
Trump's endless obstructive acts to which
Robert Mueller testified last week.
Donald Trump's violations of the Amal humans
clause.
I would even argue that Donald Trump's actions
in Yemen may be impeachable.
I did a segment about this about a month or
six weeks ago, and it is not receiving nearly
the attention as a sort of fodder for impeachment
that it probably should.
Now given that there is not a path to an impeachment
conviction with the current Republican Senate,
there are ways in which a failed impeachment
attempt could hurt Democrats and embolden
Trump.
That's a real thing.
It's important to understand that the ideal
scenario is that the impeachment inquiry itself
is what exposes Donald Trump's wrongdoing
and it takes over the new cycle.
Trump is meanwhile trying to run for reelection
and yet media because of the impeachment inquiry,
is focused on what comes out of that.
That's the ideal scenario and in the end you
hope that the publicity around what Donald
Trump has done in the content of the Mueller
report and the what would be just a treasure
trove of a, a horrible realities that would
be exposed by the impeachment inquiry would
get people not to vote for Trump in 2020 in
the end when you really think it through,
it's of should be an apolitical decision for
our elected officials to make.
What I mean by that is I understand Democrats
thinking through the strategy of an impeachment
inquiry and the timing of an impeachment inquiry,
but congress is supposed to keep the executive
branch in check.
The best argument I've heard for why the impeachment
inquiry must start, and it must start now,
is simply that it's the job of Congress, period.
The political calculation.
I understand it's important.
I'm okay with Democrats timing the impeachment
inquiry to do maximum damage to Trump for
editorial purposes, but in the end, the best
argument for why this impeachment inquiries
should get going is that it is the duty of
Congress period.
And that all political considerations should
become secondary or even irrelevant to that
decision.
I know that it's not practical in this highly
politicized and partisan world in which we
live, but it is the job of Congress to do
this.
105 Democrats now say it's time to get it
going.